n'était-ce pas terrible de continuer à travailler alors que
tant de gens considéraient que vous aviez produit
votre chef-d'œuvre avec le Velvet
Underground
non je ne regrettais aucune des choses
de la Bible je veux dire ce qui s'est
passé
quand vous avez quitté le Pays de Galles musique classique esthétique
à Londres  quelle était votre ambition
d'aller à New York
et d'
obtenir des connexions Fame et Fortune
avec un mouvement Fluxus
avant de partir pour les États-Unis ?
quelque chose à voir avec ça ce qui t'a fait
quitter Sati pour le rock and roll
eh bien je suis tombé sur Lou Reed
et j'étais intéressé par la prise de risque et
Lou m'a fait découvrir un tout autre monde
de prise de risque vous souvenez-vous de la première
fois que vous vous êtes rencontré  Lou Reed ouais je
faisais du café avec le
robinet d'eau chaude
dans l'évier de la maison de disques tu te
souviens quand Andy est venu voir The
Velvet Underground au café Bazaar euh
oui je me souviens  Il y avait tout un
Entourage qui a marché au milieu
du set et nous étions sur le point d'être virés
et c'était donc la dernière fois que nous
jouions là
-bas et après que nous avons été virés, les choses se
sont beaucoup éclaircies
quand il a produit le premier album des Stooges.
vous vous comportez comme Andy produisant The
Velvet
je pense que les Stooges ont été découverts ouais
ils n'avaient vraiment pas besoin de beaucoup de direction
et c'était juste une question d'appuyer sur
le bouton d'enregistrement et de
dire merci beaucoup qu'avez-vous
pensé d'Andy en tant que peintre  eh bien, quand je
suis allé à l'usine pour la première fois, j'ai découvert
que ça ne s'appelait pas une usine pour
rien,
il y avait des gens qui travaillaient très
très dur tout le temps et je n'avais jamais
été capable de rassembler dans mon esprit
quel genre de qualités  Je cherchais
dans l'art contemporain comme vous le trouvez dans
les maîtres anciens qui semblaient avoir
beaucoup de travail en détail et avec
Andy c'était la couleur c'était la variété
la simplicité des couleurs et la façon dont
elles étaient très surprenantes  g et très clair
pourquoi pensez-vous que les velours sont devenus
un tel culte
probablement parce que nous parlions de
choses très difficiles c'était probablement un
esprit là-bas auquel les gens
s'identifiaient vraiment je ne suis pas assez objectif pour
en parler et aussi que nous
nous  pourraient être considérés comme des échecs parce que
je veux dire que nous pourrions être considérés comme des succès
parce que nous étions des échecs et nous avons vécu
nos échecs avec beaucoup de style que
pensez-vous de la scission de Velvet Je pense que
cela a probablement commencé quand Lou a
dit à Andy qu'il ne voulait pas le faire
courir  plus
et les choses ont juste empiré à partir de là
en ce sens que nous n'avions personne là-bas qui était
vraiment
un conspirateur avec nous
et il était toujours là pour nous rappeler
toutes les idées folles que nous avions et que nous
devrions continuer avec elles quand Andy est parti
il ​​y avait  personne là-bas à qui nous pourrions faire
rebondir des idées et euh
nous avons juste fini par être un Road Band, ce qui
est très douloureux,
je pense que toutes ces idées que nous avions juste en
quelque sorte disparues dans Thin Air Lou et
yo  tu aurais pu être comme Leonard
McCartney Jagger Richards ou Rogers et
Hart
êtes-vous d'accord avec cette
idée très flatteuse
vous restez toujours en contact avec Sterling
Morrison et motaka
oui je les vois et leur parle souvent
ouais j'aime Sterling et et le
style Sterling  de conversation beaucoup et
ça me manque
ce qu'un sterling et Moe font maintenant
bien diplômé de Sterling c'est maintenant le Dr
Sterling Morrison et Maureen a
enregistré et fait beaucoup de tournées comme
vous le savez et
je pense que Sterling veut
s'intéresser à la guitare  jouer à nouveau, il
n'a jamais abandonné mais je veux dire qu'il est toujours
là et il je pense
qu'il souhaite qu'il y ait un endroit où
il pourrait accrocher son chapeau quand avez-vous
vu Andy pour la dernière fois
je pense que nous parlions j'avais l'habitude de
monter et  faire de l'exercice avec lui le matin,
il avait une personne qui est venue et a
fait un exercice individuel
et nous avons commencé à discuter d'
une vidéo d'exercice anti-war Hall avec de la
musique
et je suis parti en tournée et
j'ai entendu le  e mauvaise nouvelle quand j'étais en
pleine tournée quand as-tu vu Nico
la
dernière c'était à Bruxelles lors d'un concert
et
on vient de voyager à travers le Japon
et elle était avec un groupe et
euh
on jouait ensemble au coeur du
Bazar  à Bruxelles, quand tu as rencontré Lou aux
funérailles d'Andy,
depuis combien de temps l'as-
tu vu ?  Les
redevances du Velvet Underground que nous
avons finalement découvert
comment avez-vous réussi à retravailler avec Lou
Reed après si longtemps et bien c'était
très excitant, je veux dire que nous savions tous les deux
que nous avions beaucoup de terrain
à rattraper  car et
j'étais vraiment intéressé à former à
nouveau ce partenariat et
[Music]
il était très important pour moi de voir si
l'énergie et l'agressivité étaient toujours
là et c'était et c'était très
excitant et gratifiant et combien de temps
cela vous a-t-il pris pour  résumer Andy Warhol en 15
chansons
environ 10 jours saviez-vous qu'à propos des
chansons pour le général Lewis a dit que Regina ne peut
travailler que tous les 20 ans je ne savais pas
qu'il a dit cela a-t-il dit que ce
n'est pas étrange que Lou's Berlin et
votre Paris 1919 vos meilleurs albums après
le  Velvet Underground ne sont pas des
albums de rock and roll ouais j'adore Berlin
je ne savais pas ce que Lou en pensait mais
j'admire ce morceau n'était-ce pas terrible
de continuer à travailler alors que tant de gens
considéraient que tu avais produit ton chef-d'œuvre
avec le Velvet Underground
non  Je n'ai regretté aucune des choses
du monde, je veux dire ce qui s'est
passé et
si je savais que nous
nous reverrions ou non, je ne sais pas, mais
euh
je pense qu'il y avait tellement de choses
qui n'avaient pas été terminées  que si nous en avions
l'occasion, je savais que
nous prendrions vraiment la balle par les cornes
et ferions beaucoup
et je pense toujours que nous pouvons faire beaucoup quels
artistes aimeriez-vous produire maintenant
Bob Dylan
quel serait votre prochain album
c'est euh c'est une autre collaboration  on avec
Brian Eno
et c'est avec c'est une collaboration rock and roll
on utilise la
section rythmique des Neville Brothers
et ce sera un
album rock and roll très simple